what seems to happen in the psychedelic
state is that when something is positive
it has the potential to be incredibly
positive to the extent of being euphoric
and ecstatic but similarly if something
is negative it has the potential to be
quite hellish and dysphoric and
frightening
psilocybin is found in magic mushrooms
and it's a compound that is broken down
in the body into another compound which
is very very similar to a naturally
occurring neurotransmitter in the brain
or chemical messenger in the brain and
that's called serotonin now their
pharmacology is subtly different but
what's so interesting about this drug is
that that subtle difference in its
pharmacology confers profound effects on
consciousness our first study was
published in 2006 in healthy volunteers
who received psilocybin or a comparator
drug this was all in a blinded fashion
under optimally supported conditions in
which they laid down on the couch had
eye shades on headphones through which
they listened to a program of recorded
music they were in the presence of two
people with whom they had already
developed a trusting relationship and
under those conditions a high percentage
of people end up reporting a
constellation of experiences the most
interesting piece of which is that it
really falls into a category of
something that psychology of religion
people talk about is a primary mystical
experience analogy that you could use to
describe how the drug affects brain
activity is either to say that brain
activity becomes relatively disordered
or disorganized in the state another
thing that you could say is that it's
not entire disorder that rather it's
more like the brain enters a more kind
of anarchic state it's fascinating I
think one of the interesting
implications of this kind of work is
that we're biologically hardwired for
having these kinds of experiences it's
not just unique to
mystics you know spending years of
meditation and a kay
if that this is part of the human
biology to have these kind of
integrative experiences that can really
set the stage in the platform for
remarkable personal change then our
research has really been looking at how
it works in the brain so we've used a
number of different brain imaging
imaging modalities or brain scanning
modalities
one of them's functional magnetic
resonance imaging which uses high high
field magnets to look at changes in
brain blood flow the brain imaging work
that we've done one of the interesting
findings was that there's there was a
really quite marked decrease in brain
activity in a particular region of the
brain which is overactive in depression
so this region of the prefrontal cortex
is typically highly active in depression
and a range of effective treatments for
depression or normalize this over
activity in this region of the
prefrontal cortex and psilocybin did
exactly that and it did it very rapidly
we're running two different trials now
at Johns Hopkins one is in cancer
patients who are anxious or depressed
secondary to their cancer diagnosis
generally a life-threatening cancer
diagnosis although we haven't touched
their disease process they still
experience the pain they're still
dealing with the fact that they're going
to leave their loved rundt ones or their
children in some cases these are parents
of kids who are who are young that
sadness is still there but there's also
a larger framing of that and so it's
very touching there's a growing
consensus among scientists that drug
laws and prohibition around psychedelic
drugs is irrational it's unhelpful and
it potentially it's it's precluding
people who run well getting effective
treatments that's a shame these are
remarkable compounds with I think
remarkable implications if we can
understand how they work and why they
work